it's rented wednesday guys right way
today and we are wet i look good wet i
look good wet I'm wearing the new abbot
kinney Fight Club jacket by roots of
flight you'll you know I'll take mine it
doesn't look like that we look like
we're blending into the chair like we
looked a couple twinsies no I don't well
we are eight we are blending the chair B
we look like am I too old aware I'm a
little old right with all the little
strands weren't you look you look yeah
you look like it yeah but I'm just I
might be a little too ranked up to wear
this now I need to be a little bit more
the patches like a little younger you
know what I mean if I'm walking around
with this we go hey Bry what's going on
here what's going on here what's going
on your Corvette that's it yeah
that's in and can't do that there are a
lot of things can't do now gotta be
careful it's just a bad casting of sons
of anarchy and here in the background is
the older gentleman I'm gonna sit in the
biker gang for years and years here's
what mastermind here's what's daddy's
doing daddy's buying cool Nike sneakers
like which you know zooms things that
just look good this blending with my
jeans
I'll wear that because they're easy on
my feet easy on the feet okay I got a
couple chains maybe two or three pairs
jeans I wear two three coaches yeah sure
and I wear I wear long shirts from
somewhere good like ragam bone and then
just cashmere sweaters oh well yes man
yeah bad daddy keeps it simple lines
clean and simple now where we go there
now now now now I don't know we wigging
it I'm not wigging it dude I don't like
wake up hold on my propecia is in the
mail from hims true story okay my got to
get my hair well when I'm in the chair
on schooled they they tend to paint my
head they paint my scalp because they
were dust lay there they were dusting it
and I would sneeze it would get in my
nose oh yeah those tiny follicles get in
your sinuses that's a big problem
because I'm trying to shoot and blow the
easing my ass and it's also pain they
also you know these are tiny tiny hair
follicles here's what they also saw yeah
here's what they don't tell you as well
to get in your eyes
tiny little sharp hairs getting your
eyes so now that now they're using that
spray like the little like airbrush gun
yeah to get like the air raise me up a
little bit they always win it like you
certain last time they did Oh on Comedy
Central
they always spray right I have that cuz
you know yeah comic Alec yeah they
always spray I'm like no that's it's the
way it grows baby leave it like on TV
you got thick you got thick hair thick
dude thick skin from sports
I noticed that athletes we spend a lot
of time in common sports there that the
skin on their face gets thick you Donald
Cerrone thick skin the caveman forehead
came from football cuz you always
wearing the helmet oh it's like so you
I'm tree and puzzle face you probably
built like a callus of sorts under the
sea I'm sure dude yeah you callus head
out dude it's wrench it up Wednesday its
wrench it up Wednesday wrench it up guys
that's what Brennan said its wrench it
well thanks everyone said guys let's
wrench it up Wednesday wrench it up see
in studio yeah I like saying stuff like
that when I go when I step around the
gym now you know what I say I go let's
go to church [ __ ] hell yeah dude
that's like coffee no prisoners when I
got my coffee I feel it so you know that
um would you calm chanting he's not
transgender he's just a he was born a
male but dresses like a lady with a
beard no she doesn't have a beard but
she he is it's a boy who was born with
very feminine features and has nails and
dresses like a female huh the one who
makes coffee oh I I'm I'm now with the
pouty lip how you know we all joke
around I am actually attractive
attractive yeah I mean I was I 80
percent serious I was like I wonder if I
was a little drunk two glasses in ah
well two glasses in I'm telling you now
I've had to get experiences that I'm
gonna share with you and I'm even gonna
read a text I had to send it I two
glasses of wine with the right
circumstances I would probably make out
with that dude pretty little lip I like
his mouth kid and he's also super aloof
to me oh he's also not into me as a
human he like I may as well be a [ __ ]
spore nothing like a mushroom but when I
have
it calor someone picked up my coffee
went yeah that's more the big boy is how
would he say yes so then - how about
today
really she's a Detroit he made a little
bit of a move because it was just him
and I yeah and I was getting me oh my
americano extra shot I try he knows how
daddy like yeah okay all right it's
raining out guys you're safe it's rainy
out in LA zone around I go la city shuts
down no rain and she or he goes you tell
me there's nobody around I think yeah
nobody around and then I went then he's
making the coffee oh oh you know what
can I go up to I'll take mine your
cookies - I love the cookies he goes
you're sweet and then there's just meet
him in the rain hey dude can people are
listening I sing that were gay I start
that man y'all was gonna say you're
right that we're gay but not gay and I
would suck his dick but gays in I would
let him will pound at home he's got he's
so pretty and he's soft and he's so
[ __ ] he's so I just don't care like
he hides behind his hair too cool for
that coffee I know it he wears his
shirts open yeah like he will surely
navel but he's got she's got like a soft
girl sketch it's like that nice not a
stitch of hair he made cooker emojis he
makes a Korean look Harry Russian me ah
so here Italian marble but he wants
nothing to do like nothing was like
tangy with coffee it's like you're
annoying you try to make him laugh he
costs us to reach cuz we're performers
so if we have an audience that if we're
you guys start honking around we bomb
every time ate [ __ ] we [ __ ] with each
other he's done he likes coffee he likes
his coffee called I like my nothing no
dude nothing and if it's one I want his
approval so I went over there and let
tits up like this well I had a gay thing
with me I don't care bro right off take
yours off cuz it's a little high
oh you're wearing it
you're wearing a jumper no oh no a pop
my [ __ ] gas pump Mike I guess that's
why homegirl hit on me some mean this no
that's not why
yeah that's not why hit man this jumper
how about to drop drop my car off this
morning parsha yeah and I was dressed
exactly like the mechanics really I
looked exactly like them there's just as
a Porsche log on it and I'm kind of
jelly
I had a jelly means Joseph challenged le
I know what jelly beans I so I'm I go to
buy some some sweaters from Vince let me
guess - gray yeah black right blue yeah
yeah whatever yeah but um there's a
gentleman he's got a tiny bit of an
accent
and he he was astonishingly good looking
oh yeah astonishing so [ __ ] flirty
and kinda just bad boy I mean he was
just like the odds like the way he told
me to take care of my sweater take this
brush just coming out and I was like hey
man stop it sparks were flying high I
was like what's going on and I'm old you
know he was um oh he's a tween so I got
my sweaters Winky he was a [ __ ] twink
but oh did you talk well I had two texts
D'Elia Sasso and uh and my buddy
Marshall I love because I was he's so
funny he's because I had to I you can't
feel gay and then not tell your friends
about it because what'll happen is it'll
percolate into I might move in with him
and now I'm I'm [ __ ] chasing him down
to see where the [ __ ] next thing you
know it says suckin dick once a week
you're doing it twice the week you know
I'm saying that's right that's exactly
right
yeah once week now yeah so you can't
take I don't yeah but he was one of
those guys who makes you feel like the
world is okay here army guys were like
do you feel safe yeah you feel safe yeah
there's no cuz that life is a
competition so when you're around doujin
like other on dudes I'm never gonna cry
around my friends like this these
[ __ ] because they might take all my
[ __ ] sure you know there
competitive carnivores yeah but not this
guy no not this guy and I go so I'm
gonna read this I wrote this to these
guys I just had a love it men I go hey
guys I come up I met a man named Alex
he's from Montreal he keeps a pink pony
tail on the top of his perfect head
he wears stylish glasses and his eyes
are the bluest blue and they are shaped
like my heart we spoke French he's tall
and I would need only one glass of wine
to kiss him for a long time now
my friend Marshall goes doesn't seem to
me like you need any wine go for broke
you guys would [ __ ] with me judge me
Marshall goes us bro no way do it and
send pics of you doing it where we can
clearly see your face I will prove to
you you can trust us Julia goes agreed
that was very good so did you come on
man yeah there's that guy better than
homeboy at the coffee place home way the
copy place ah when I get my government I
think there we go I was very tired
yeah I don't know dude sometimes Styria
men can have a mistake they can have
that feminine I mean look I'm a very
straight man but sometimes you meet a
man who's got a lot more feminine energy
than male you do you go I get it you get
it I get it if you are spending time
with him in a place like an island or a
jail or LA you you will be one of those
escape room that's it you can you you
were trying to scooter it out on
yourself in his arms
ah you would be in yeah he'd be in your
ax
he'd be in my arms oh no no don't hold
on and he's spice he seems like he's
gonna yeah like he's gonna easy attitude
he's my baby just man yeah he's you've
dealt with him cat boy man he's my boy
and I'll tell you something if I'm
dating our boy over here should really
do his nails I'm telling you right now
if he [ __ ] names like malaria I'd be
a I'd be I'd be daddy and I
come over here the [ __ ] you done why are
you talking to us guys what do you do
what's [ __ ] no no you guys you're
going to work out where where are you
gonna work out where 24 hour fitness by
the 11 and your ass like that well
you're an ass like that well here's a
kick up couple things
no you're not no you're not okay stretch
I'm gonna work you out right now yeah
because I don't think if I see it from
the other side
uh-huh you see the people no nobody say
anything about anal stop I'm just
talking about I'm just talking about if
I was that's how I picture it going down
with you and him well I don't just tell
you that but that happens you know we're
men my buddy my buddy is he's a dude
folks guys my friends are like that
what's up episode super okay oh my super
Oh moronic look man the bottom line is
it's where we come out this one makes me
ten percent game and it's actually on
the jacket oh my god oh my god that's
fantastic and then was there some on the
other side it's just on the back just on
the back is that might be my favorite
jacket of all time that's a great jacket
I love women I just yeah the Fight Club
thing I hate when people ask me about
the Fight Club Oh where's the German
Venice
god damn it dude god dammit you know
where this is frank grillo he's sherwood
Frank all the goodness I sure would like
it might fit am i gifted to him he's a
little thick well we're gonna get a list
for all our friends there make him like
chin paid for his last time like a done
so mixed sugar to make sure why dude
serves us we crave this job
well where do these bad boys running on
the website uh with a discount 225 there
you go
it's good you know expensive girl to
make a good deal and they're only doing
pre-sales cuz I love this like a racecar
Jacob us you have something to do with
designing this all Papa look at the back
come on
you're like biker gangs you shop yeah we
don't I get in trouble any biker gangs
we're not we're completely safe this is
nowhere near if you let what they do
it's it's obviously of similar vibe but
has nothing to do with any biker gang
okay it says 10% yay yeah biker gang of
Cox yeah we're gonna hunt you down oh
you're the gang of old ladies what
little birds with burn burn dude I can
biggie you on just to hogs yeah but and
then little over say what should the
name of the coffee boy be I don't know
let's call him my list no hole Ellis
Ellis you Donna Ellis
soft smoke soft smoke soft smokey about
soft-serve he's smoking and he's soft
he's smoking on saw smoke yeah we kill a
better name how about how about how
about um how feels spicy how about
butter boy nope but I got no butter no
keys those mysterious little aloof
butter smoke hey I like butter I liked a
little hit little haze Oh
little hey hazy butter haze hey can we
say butter can we say hazy hazy hazy
hazy come back hazy don't I don't don't
cheapen my experience hey hold on all
[ __ ] aside
don't talk about my boyfriend like that
dude careful okay - gets me I'm already
I feel aggressive today
threw my back out yesterday so I'm a
little tender but don't talk about my
boyfriend like that because I don't give
a [ __ ] about you right you know he did
what hey little hey saw the Diamonds lit
dad no no I know you got an edge I'm not
gonna lie you got an edge on God you
talk a good game I talk again talk your
way and uh hard to break a boy down now
um oh he filled it up with it either no
he's not [ __ ] God you get no wind I got
to take him shopping all the time Oh
stand it and then
want that ass know what he does he
cheats on me with you Oh at least more
than me ever the whole city's running on
them
Oh God whole city's running on about
they're looking for your credit Brad
white much have you seen Hayes have you
seen him buddy seen little Hayes where
the [ __ ] he left us morning and we gotta
fight god damn it straight waxes [ __ ]
I check on to all the waxing plays oh
he's nude like a the old boy there's not
an ounce of hair on that man
how's he shave there's nothing kid
doesn't need to maybe he is he is I
would I would I would like a contest to
count hairs who's here your cat or him
probably me I don't he is hairless he's
just a PG he has hair only where he
needs it eyebrows and like his head of
hair like a though it's a diamond he's a
time in the rough for some gay man yeah
or straight guys like us or do you oh
yeah I was just running with this
because I want you to feel oh listen to
you
zone okay little haze for you but guess
what there's only one game on this mmt I
will guarantee if nobody's looking you
only one of those mortal enemy summer it
doesn't matter you don't come after me
they went after you but her closet perv
and I believe in my heart have I seen
[ __ ] porn yeah dude it popped up and I
was like why I got it look I watch I got
a look like faces of death I'm gonna
look see how it ends for people
yeah that's those longer allowed I don't
think it's allowed I don't think so
oh my bad well that's how you porn
organizes their catalogue not my fault
not my thing
- you porn mm-hmm talk to them dude
important isn't politically correct
that's crazy - I might've made that how
do we Howard this is why at 52 when
people say I wanna listen your podcast
and I'm talking to respectful is the boy
I go don't don't listen to my podcast
it's not for you I don't know who it's
for anymore the people so Daniel I'll
tell you who is on t 5k subscribers in
the month well I love it because when
I'm at the Rams game and I'm walking up
to get my beer those are my people just
too much
dudes oh that's all right yeah six bros
is it the greatest it's the [ __ ]
greatest do you mean they're not yelling
out gold Birds no I've never heard that
one I've never been with you god bless
oh you know what when we're in Vegas
that kind of I'll get fam the fan I'm at
the airport family's you were ahead of a
in Vegas yeah I'll get families to come
up and they just love cuz it's they
watch it with their kids yeah you know
here's a good show
yeah I mean you're getting fired now
though they find out you're into the
coffee guy but whatever
daddy got picked up for nine episodes
but that's not a full season right it is
in 22 episodes all season oh oh because
they were because it was only I was only
13 13 oh good Nancy and it's interesting
and important because in my 25 years
it's never happened never happened dude
do you first off congrats student you
remember when we're yeah we're waiting
to find out if you got the pilot the
pilot and they first called you and said
you did it and you called me first
yeah come in right cut picture Mike you
are anything you do anything on you in
Denver this is ten years ago that's
exactly right
two years ago exactly anyway Bubba
didn't get it I'm so heartbroken for you
nothing about that but but you're my guy
so much Ryan man I started crying I was
so heartbroken for you and then boom
dude 22 episodes but remember how
resigned I was I was like I just went
about my day because that's the way it
always enjoyed nice you know what but
you pretended you're like always witness
up dude I don't mind looking at my phone
I was like you're annoying me act like
you care cuz you do care you can't help
but care I get plus you can't help but
care whenever you try for anything in
life and you know the one thing that I
always see is like it's really hard to
go for something because then you have
to admit that you really want it and
then you have to admit that you might
fail and you are gonna fail and that's
what's so hard about it like admitting
what you want everyone sees it though to
in the business when everyone's gonna
see your failure I know cuz like fitting
it picked up for the pilot ones like
guess Brian's pilot didn't get picked up
like yeah dude yeah you don't see it it
didn't get picked up yeah so we all know
yeah yeah and this whole business that
we're in is if
you're not if you're not trying if
you're not going for it you're gonna be
surpassed by people that are like
there's no way to not take all of it
personally in acting and stand up and
the thing about stand-up is we I was
talking to Russell Peters about this
like rustles rustles you know couldn't
be more successful than Russell's at the
Comedy Store every [ __ ] day why he
goes he goes I go I'm not competitive
that way because no you're not but the
audience is and the audience can see the
difference and he goes when I went to
Comedy Store
I get nervous this Russell Peters saying
I get nervous because I'm I'm gonna line
up with monsters other percent and and
so you there are a lot of guys that are
really famous there who are around do
they it could be like Eddie Murphy it
could be someone like that those guys
are not gonna they're not gonna come
back as great as they are they're not
gonna come back and just jump into a
lineup like that at The Comedy Store and
I don't play notes batting practice then
those guys are in there all the time
batting and then you've taken years off
you can we go let me get some swings
with that 90 mile an hour fast yeah
you're gonna strike you don't want to go
between Theo von and Joey Diaz and
Anderson Tino you don't want to do that
with all because these guys are it's
like it's like fighting your guys are in
the race like there's no they don't have
any ring rest of those guys are in the
race yeah and there's no way to not
constantly be attached to you should you
should be open about wanting [ __ ] I
guess is what I'm saying
I never very open yeah you're very oh
yeah you were killing it you you know
you were you were [ __ ] me I was
watching you at the ice house it was Sam
Sam Triple E killing me
Sam Triple E [ __ ] just so funny and
then you got up and you were [ __ ]
that you were you were destroying it I
was it was it was so for that some of
that new [ __ ] that you're doing now it's
just so funny to me because we don't see
each other a lot and outside this we've
really don't see each other you know and
we don't watch each other doing you
never watch your friends do stand-up
very real and the watch that you watch I
guys you never see like if whatever mark
Norman's are Schultz is there burrs on
there who we don't see a ton you'll
watch them but we're always Ranchos so
he'll like I'll go and then Brian's
going on like I do I'm in the back doc
so on when I get my car and leave but
the good thing about you and I think
anybody is that you're you just keep
moving forward like that sometimes you
throw all the self-help [ __ ] out the
window and just
go hey just keep doing it you just keep
doing it you just keep doing it
I think every comic does it know this
you get to know the problem a lot of
comics if they stopped writing got a
comics stop they stop growing it's just
really easy to do it's really easy to
sit with one set and that's a not a good
idea
nowadays it's not what can you do man
I'm just too competitive
yeah but wanting even my speaking a
wanting to do you want to go over that
coffee shop and just shoot your shot
shooter shoot haters hate yeah oh no man
you shot dude
no I'm shy now why do have this new
fracking dude I feel like you would have
this go no you know what I do I could
take it off and give it to him owner uh
what you won't wear this or he you know
you I know he's given he's a bad boy you
know he's gonna do he's gonna cut it up
he's gonna make it his own have his own
patches on sleeveless it's gonna be it's
gonna be easy and put on the back owned
by the kid yeah he's gonna rip off just
the fighter and she was say on top owned
by or the kids property that's guys one
of those hog babes you know what kind of
buddy there's nobody called hog babes hi
[ __ ] a Razorback like your old old
lady yeah I'll put the kids old lady
he's all ya little pouty lips I like
what bothers me when you here go to the
gym and you see do to where they just
have picked out their outfit huh little
to match your outfit they got they got
not just a headband but also a hat on
top of the headband they got a whole
time but that's hat twos or you know I
used to judge those guys that don't need
more cuz that's their time that's their
stage time that's their time they might
work some 9:00 to 5:00 and then I got
there they got we're [ __ ] suit all
like do the sucks but they can't wait to
get to the gym because there's got that
new outfit from Nike town trying to
press some chick I was with rent in one
time and I was meeting I was watching
you you need very strong guy and I was
watching a guy who was dead lifting and
he had his shirt off and he had a
mouthpiece in and he had it wasn't
enough to put the weight on the
in our he also had chains around not
only not only on the bar but also on his
neck see but I don't judge those guys
what would be what when you went do too
much and I went when I say went you know
what if I had his body up I have my
shirt off I know whose body deploy
thought it was it was also like but he
had a mouthpiece hence cuz it was such
much so halfway they like the bones
weight and I said when I go hey Brent
could you uh lift that right now without
a mouthpiece your brother said he'll
stay he could wake up from a nap right
he can wake up from an apple go over
there and talk cuz you know Jay can't
steal any hear that stuff and I was like
aha mouthpieces of extreme I wonder if
that guy knew that that was the case
with you know I think he's afraid that's
this thing saying that's the thing you
gotta be careful with it when it when
it's your thing and you're that proud of
it and it's that's his one thing yeah
it's that's all your checks
I know but can I just say one thing it's
also it's also not to be mean but it's
also nothing I know also hey hey this
it's nothing but if that's your one
thing I know you're not a pro peacock
you can get a look it's young man
warrior energy that doesn't know where
to go oh I know I was gonna tell you I
served was I finally started watching
Sopranos last night watch the first
episode thank you I'm in I know oh oh
yeah dude I've been depressed I finished
True Blood that was my [ __ ] man Sookie
how can you like Compton I loved it
even the end loved the fairy stuff loved
it
no complaints well I love were you with
me I wanted to hurt it I wanted Sookie
to a venture turning a vampire and B you
know either Bill Compton's or the other
dude mode is my favorite kick of all
time
the [ __ ] is his name Eric Eric Northman
is my favorite character of all time of
any series who is he and all he's this
true of a bad boy vampire bring housing
here's what's his last name
your Accord real pale he's gorgeous eyes
he played yacht on TR team I know I know
exactly Eric Northman
hey sweet oh yeah that's a ma Amanda
rulesets with I'm obsessed how she was
obsessed with hold up what do you think
I grew my hair out bro oh god you're
sick piece of [ __ ] dude I've had it no
you [ __ ] check I'm a True Blood you
[ __ ] no I'm a trainee I'm a true baby
ah yeah I'm a blood baby okay look at
him dude look at my hiny being I know
look about I'm gonna get him I'm not
gonna look at you anyway but also Eric
Northman hope you wander there no I've
been influenced by three men by three
jared leto
I know kind of to do love I still love
him alright just cuz Gucci makes it
doesn't mean yes the three men you're
never gonna guess all right
it's dak Shepherd okay I've Dax ears
long let's have him on the podcast yeah
he has a huge part podcast so I'm chair
expert yeah he's so 'some you you guys
have lost similarities I know everybody
says that we have like no friends never
met me I love him he lives in Bettis
anyway so Eric Northman for growing my
hair ready Eric Northman fave I love
that man this is super Eric Northman
though now go to the we're up from True
Blood it was also made to Sophia my
favorite is a werewolf we're welcome
it's my favorite yeah you guys know it's
werewolf that's the only time wolf you
have a speech manner but me you've
killed it that's where I work at it
killed it the only place I'll that's my
boy Joe my boy that's my boy dude so hey
here real quick
Joanna's ground Joanna's mom's watching
True Blood with us and she goes huh and
she debrief don't say it you know her
she's broken English goes huh she goes
if you're in True Blood you'd be a you'd
be just like Kim on it what do you say
and I went I should grow my hair out
yeah look at him how JoJo's every bit of
240 he's every Bob dude he is he's a
very big shred Cydia and a great guy so
so it's him as a werewolf in True Blood
where Eric Northman Northman werewolf
Eric Northman this werewolf and that
Shepard
this way yeah go zr3 those are my 3
North Stars that's in those are my North
Stars that's incredible but it all
started with Eric Eric Northman were you
with me when do you ever seen Six Feet
Under
no I don't know if you remember this you
were with me we came into my house it
was when you and I first met and Amanda
go to Eric my wife hearts my wife
started to cry she started crying we
walked the house and she started ball
why and I go what's what's wrong what's
wrong was wrong and it was because she'd
watched the final episode of [ __ ] Six
Feet Under
she was still upset about you I can see
how people get at that like with the Wiz
crew blood I was it was my thing I was
so into it you know I'm really into
right now like you helped Eric Northman
got shred City for Tarzan dude yes
that's pretty she said for dude he looks
stupid Farzin that's [ __ ] terrible
movie he looks he looks good you see it
no it's Tarzan don't be jelly dude look
at him look at him no hit him is a
vampire's just I'll never get I got a
great body there in Christ
that's the Swede doing what happened to
me I never got those arms look at him in
True Blood look at him it's [ __ ]
Tarzana that's good I think everybody
should be on T our TV no I don't know if
that's just here TV I think it's a cut
both yeah so Tru Bloods over I start
Sopranos last night first episode have
you seen it yet
Sopranos no I haven't have you seen chin
of course love it love it favorite show
ever
enough ever but I love it ulanovsky
Brian loves it so right now yeah I know
Stevie that's why I heard I get Sopranos
and then also Rick and Morty you just
did that like so naturally
ok shag is hard and time to mourn it's
you and me dude man so Rick is his
grandpa and that's his bad side it's the
most creative cartoon than you Plastic
Man can I see that back what can you
play that moment back did your recording
is there any way to do you it it's uh
it's definitely adult cartoon my son
loves it I watch them with them but I
think you would like it it's uh it's so
well done it's it's a 100 what would
they call them Emmys it won a bunch of
[ __ ] Emmy
Wow amazing Elon Musk was a character on
it
Elon tusks kanye West is gonna guess you
want us but it's just like it's just so
it's like such a smart cartoon ah it's
such a smart cut okay because the dads
uh he's the smartest person in the
universe there's all these yeah they're
though I'm sorry the grandpa here's all
these gadgets they go to different
dimensions in weird show it's yeah it's
watch it or is it adults uh definitely
more for adults but my son watch it
don't really know what's going on they
bleep out the bad words they do cos like
it'd be like don't be a [ __ ] idiot
Morty like hell yeah dude yeah think so
I started cussing at you okay it's so
good though anyway else brick Morty I've
heard about so many times by nursing
humor haze their fights on yeah you can
just say these nuts in your mouth
no no hey we want being gating you being
aggressive yeah do you are saying gotcha
huh
yeah Northland fired me up and you not
knowing Ricky Moore you really pissed me
off
how about man come on I gotta watch it
now this is this why do the podcast um
there's yeah I'll stroll dream and gross
and Stroke Rosen stroke
oh did you know who rose and strew kids
oh he's a beast
I'm sure big huge guy for this game
someone's celebrating I don't know I
heard somebody like scream it's tough to
tell if it's like a murder or
celebration Joshua and yeah that's a big
white that's what yeah
and I can someone sent me a thing Joshua
apparently got knocked out in training
again what he did who knows if it's just
the rumor mill and people are just
trying to get conspiracies going but and
then in the open workout for the media
injuries is doing work on this bag and
Joshua's just shadow boxing so
everyone's like ooh
big fight for Joshua he's making 75
million it's kind of like the biggest
fight for Joshua you can break because
you slide right up right off to the
sunset and if he doesn't win there's a
truckload of money yeah I think he jumps
down a bunch of gold coins in England I
wonder if he has sex with girls I don't
I don't think they like him at all he's
not attractive look at that look at that
size difference Josh was at your life
thinner this done
he's letting her guys lost some weight
hmm that's a big one for him though man
I'm man I know I know but you know watch
it they can't wait call up [ __ ]
Stallone see if you can [ __ ] might be
there both Stallone and the boys have
been in my writing let's see what's up
dude could be could be that I was
invited already if the boys are lots of
famous people how much taller how tall
is Joshua and how tall is relieves read
is actually pretty tall he's short fat
he's actually tall duh well I mean
compared Josh looks since four I think
Josh would survive
no no Wilder six seven six seven six
eight three six figure and so Wilders so
really that mean I gotta be Daenerys is
511 oh yeah I would assume six six he's
about 65 and then you know Wilders legit
six seven inch six eight fury six eight
the huge is so big yard Fury was even
six nine we've stood next to them so
huge you have the other huge be
interests he yeah he definitely needs to
win this fight Louise looks like he's
trimmed down a little bit that's I think
the older one that's the other one he
sees thick
mmm-hmm who's that guy Povetkin I think
oh yeah so you can watch with the bullet
the TA I tell you is the TRT boys are
you talking about
yeah here the TRT boys I'm sorry I don't
know what you're saying I do you know
what I love I get on that ship mm-hmm I
need to know there are three years no
I'm gonna watch it on the road I mean
hey you know what I'm doing I'm gonna go
down and ten Diego maybe when you're
when you're there and I'm going to get a
one it's a day long or like you know you
pay a lot of money to have like every
conceivable test done by the longevity
experts where they look at everything
they tell you when you're gonna die
basically I don't want to know that one
feel like a duty of four years now that
that's interesting though cuz you get a
like a like it's like a check-up on
steroids like every little [ __ ]
detail just want to see what's up in
does insurance cover any of it I don't
know but it's in San Diego yeah you know
Thursday Friday Saturday we should you
and I fix the weather two days we'll try
see what your testosterone is exactly
your oxidized cholesterol I mean they go
Gina they just take your blood and then
I can leave or I might just take Larry's
back to me you know curious you do all
why you got to see it good driver saying
if I ever do trt and stuff that's the
place you go down there and they do they
dare lie you're a [ __ ] just some
[ __ ] duck and just inject no Deka
anavar so ever anavar for you do you
wear a dude thredson coat pocket in my
my my jacket pocket get it from a
reliable source
oh yeah very reliable is it a friend of
ours no it's friend of mine high level
trainer oh yeah yeah and makes it
himself did he give it to you for you or
for me he gave for me and he's like he's
like why aren't you taking it I got and
I'm afraid you guys don't be a [ __ ]
just one in the morning one at night see
what happens
do you give it up daddy you wanna give
it up I'm gonna give it to you only if
you take it I swear I'll take it
the awesomes if I get Jack city you'll
get shredded
well shred says no I don't want to get
it one of those I don't be Jack city a
lot of those CrossFit gals the high
level
that's big curlers Nana VARs an
immersive what a lot of people take
cause it's not very steroid right the
friendly steroid I love when CrossFit
that top CrossFit people are always like
I don't do steroids look at them it's a
sin it's all-natural merit that's a girl
the Purple's
[ __ ] she's that mother who's a dude
on the right purple was in Wonder Woman
wait doing what she's a yeah Brooke and
wells Brooke wells Brooke and city but
they're all they're all they're all they
mean that's that's that's not they're
sick they're awesome they're awesome but
it's not natural
that's okay here's my thing I don't give
a flatter you so I think you look super
hot when they're not in competition a
little out and they be not really the
abs you know yeah that's a lot that's a
lot a lot that's that's they're sexy I
can see they're sexy though oh yeah and
they're always asked they're always
cheek before yeah I kind of like to do
shoulders yeah the bowling ball shoulder
I agree with you I respect the [ __ ] out
of what they do is just that oh me too
can't tell me please please stop
pretending I think it'd be interesting
like if that was your girl who she's bad
yeah if that was your girl and you guys
are like in the gym together no County
cooler that it'd be cool if I was like
married to CrossFit chicken should I put
that [ __ ] down like my touchy cook you
yeah I could use that man why are you
sorry
[ __ ] put it down all right girl let's go
back to that no that's your trainer in
the middle nope that's again what that
dudes no I know that's a Korean guy I
can't tell I know it is cuz I know she
is
oh she's Korean huh I believe she's gran
she was one of the first cross
CrossFitters and she was I don't know
about now but she was she looked very
natural back in the day yeah that girls
just want to have fun but now you're
competing on a high level [ __ ] marry
kill W get tested like once a [ __ ]
year or something I say but why test
them who gives a [ __ ] yeah well
obviously obviously they don't Testament
I mean really there now there's some
baddie crime that's hot she's haha
on the left dude yeah that's that's that
is that's outstanding
all right okay man listen you don't get
in better shape
who's that guy kid nope nope no one see
the guy who's a lot of hot chicks on
there doodoo far left who said I won
this way Pass which one
yeah that one dang man she's adorable
we just start to a CrossFit dude I know
and hurt our backs um their bellies
tickle
dude uh that stuff who's doing the
deadlift they're in the throng top no no
the deadlift
I don't deadlift she's already low to
the ground there you go oh there's no
weights that's what I call good posture
so I called good time sure got us and
they're very cute man I love the cross
boy how big it was action is it how
about she want hey she was an Olympic
lifter she's amazing hey can you go to
[ __ ] Christian McCaffrey on the far
left there run in the sand the place for
Carolina Panthers best player in the
league that's all natural dude that's
Christian McCaffrey look at how shut up
the Christian death was strong way
bigger than mine that is a strong person
Wow
that's my girl right there the 101 this
one right yeah she's Olympic I mean is
that Olympic yeah she was I think she
she was old she represented like New
Zealand and Olympics or something if we
cross darling I've got yeah hmm there's
brooke pence uh the second one yeah yeah
there you go chin yeah dang look at her
waistline
yeah that's I'm not mad at it it'd be
just a little weird and go to the one
next to her chin she is sweaty scrolling
dude I dated a competitor at CrossFit
name was just um
I mean I did it competitive fitness
model back in the day and she was it's
everything is about that they're just
they're so crazy like don't drink [ __ ]
loads of coffee because it's diuretic
because it can make something like
everything they do is just about
kriya they do smell they smell different
they smell they smell different the
amount of protein they doll because
their their endocrine Sol this [ __ ]
they're taking they just smell different
everything yes that's so weird
it's well smell like it your hormonal
system is changing it's just different
smells bad or good or lessor like the
warehouse of bodybuilding calm it's not
as strong sometimes it can be a
different i'll deal with some [ __ ]
though too if they're hot enough man I
will
it's it's it's no joke the CrossFit is
no joke man is so [ __ ] hard it's not
it's not to take anything away from what
they owe it's so hard it's crazy how
like how many people are into it huh I
don't yeah it's it's really it is
amazing stuff to watch because when they
do the finish man or woman on earth they
don't know what they don't even know
what the events are gonna be there
they're surprised by them you know easy
they've done those events before they
don't know the order but no no no they
actually haven't done they'll change
[ __ ] oh no no you're gonna carry
somebody as opposed to a sandbag there's
different things like that but this is
carrying the motion and the pole up they
vault they yeah that's all they do
it's the only do so much stuff in
CrossFit they've done it before they
just don't know the order but they are
without a doubt the fittest people on
earth I mean there's a cross-section of
challenges where you're just like
alright what it what is fittest on earth
though because it's the ability to run
farther carry more weight but it's hard
to say fittest person on earth because
like if they have to do what let's say
like a cam Haines has to do they
couldn't do it but cons can't do what
they do
yeah or if you ask them to do what they
have endurance and power and speed they
have everyone football players don't or
NBA players don't I don't know that NBA
players have the kind of weightlifting
that goes on so but it's more skill it's
also physical but it's also skill
it's very sports specific I'm not saying
it on great shape these guys are doing
like this this is what bothers me to say
they're the fittest on earth is silly
because Christian McCaffrey who plays
two hours every Sunday gets hit is in
phenomenal shape it's just a different
type of shape yeah so there that's the
fittest crossfitter
you know I'm saying as a person I'm
gonna freak out that's all you could buy
yeah but that's yeah yeah I mean I know
I know saying it's just different that
guy's natural bring that guy up he's
natural that's not that's that's that's
I I don't know why anybody killed these
people aren't natural when I want them
to be on steroids I got mad at him
because they went bad and I got popped
for steroids but why even ask a young
piece of [ __ ] white like it's like the
Olympia they were going bad you know who
cares but you know do people like with
the Olympia
it doesn't mean a it's just it doesn't
mean it's not just as hard doesn't mean
it's not impossible but what it does
like you when you see that girl or if
you see the Olympia P although steroids
because there you couldn't what steroids
you still care about their body so it
gives them a reason I like that you're
talking I'm able to do that to everybody
in the field is doing something and
they're still competing at a high high
level and it's just like Lance Armstrong
everybody was do exactly that's how he's
just better at it yeah that's right
let's do some current events I gotta go
to a CrossFit gym so that's right oh
okay so this would say this was
submitted by Devin Ellis nervously hot
right there and he wants you guys to
react to this great wrestling no no no
keV on careful please don't I saw on
this video and then do this there you go
sick
that's not an that's not an uncommon
move by the way no not these days yeah
it is for back in the day yeah but these
days a lot of kids are doing it yeah
whoosh that was filthy
yeah fantastical flying suis high
resting some of the best in the country
oh yeah that was cool
yeah okay so on Monday after scoring a
touchdown the Seattle Seahawks started
to dance in the end zone and they did
their edition of new edition why does
the headline say the blackest move
momentum in history history that's weird
new edition here's what's embarrassing
you can see them practicing this good
they are no they do it they do a superb
job they did NSYNC before that there but
watching them practicing like oh that's
a bummer
taking time they're all [ __ ] one's
[ __ ] out yep but people loved it yeah
hell yeah it was great okay not so much
happening in the news but I have a
couple of silly clips so this woman went
to the airport and she got stopped by
TSA cuz something was in her bag her
checked luggage and her friend right
before they got to the airport stuck a
huge sex toy in there knowing that it
would set the Machine off yeah and just
the guy's face when he realizes what it
is like he's like girl right his face is
the best I got he probably sees that all
the time though and sees a bunch of
people just pretending embarrassed
yeah yeah the funniest thing is when you
get your luggage and then someone's law
you're just going
down the carousel funny
and then on Black Friday there is a clip
of a Best Buy manager doing the Stone
Cold Stunner with energy drinks right
before they start what is this to hype
everyone up it's all jacked this is the
music
[Applause]
well he's dead seriously it been fun if
you lose how about the guy going family
gold watch inch Toshiba TVs this Black
Friday oh boy that's a lot of - it's too
shallow [ __ ] no it'd been funny feels
like laughing but he was dead serious
yeah that's funny though
well first time unit sometimes he had a
lot of people cheering for you get get
out of yourself yeah yeah you know what
let's do this and you're like oh my god
no more it's really fun to watch people
freak out when it's their first time on
TV you know where you watch guys who are
like trying to do that there that's the
first time they're on TV and they're
talking about sports like that guy was
like boom goes the dynamite you ever
seen that one hmm we're just awkward
you never saw that there's a kid who had
his first chance to be a sportscaster oh
oh come on
mom goes the dynamite oh dude there it
is this one check oh I do remember this
that you just said nobody watching panic
hello everyone
well the Ball State softball team
continued to play this weekend and they
were hoping to continue off at their
straight three out of four losses and so
we'll take a look and see how that
happened they started off good but then
eventually but the Ball State women's
bemmon's team shot and ended up doing
poorly oh no we're gonna continue on now
the ladies Cardinals will play an Iowa
tournament started with oza riding
tomorrow's game will be the meeting
between the two beating both first
[Music]
what we star on the for on on the year
and they have won six of its last seven
games tomorrow will be the game 3 at
3:00 p.m. which switching to Ball State
men's tennis it seems last week player
on it seems every week how do you get
the job
Matt Lawrence is the latest courses like
new I try for UFC tonight my first time
I swear it's so nerve-racking matches
last what happened in 30 minutes if
you'd like
what happened me with UFC tonight and my
whole everyone blacks is there Lauren my
whole squad is there and that you do
like so they do though they do theirs
and then they bring in people they want
to try out and I go in and just happen
be that car that weekend was all foreign
Brazilian Russians and you know I
struggle with Nate oh they don't tell
you what you're gonna go over so I'm
like what and there we go they go do you
know do you know the door might hit me
go do you know the card this week on it
yeah yeah then when it's in Brazil so
you know the whole cardio the undercard
it's me in jail you know chills variety
but I love jumping Chili's totally yeah
and so it's me in jail talking and the
names I'm like I see my family oh god am
i dying I knew it didn't go well because
you get into it I went the toughest dude
I went I'll see you around
[ __ ] it not for me
I just get worse and worse I start let
me hear I don't know if you couldn't let
me know what have had a player honored
on the week on the weekly Awards seven
out of the nine at seven out of the nine
weeks the cards will played they invite
this weekend the Indiana Pacers are
looking for a measure of love and
confidence so it's like Jersey Nets and
to strengthen their playoff hopes the
next one who put this
who is his dad there's one game behind
you so young and I think it's probably
his first time being on camera
yeah this is you this is what happens
especially when you see people when they
act for the first time yeah in an acting
class where they have to sing David what
there's no say watch this watch this
right Reggie Miller's looking good he
shoots the three and it's good later
it's the rebound passes it to the man
shoots it and boom goes the dynamite
final score with the Pacers 63 to the
net 61 dissociated press this is hard
everyone poor kid so funny my promises I
didn't you have to audition something to
get on there like I'll be honest man
they said well I don't know what Network
this is but like when I first started
doing Alice work with ESPN they didn't
you know like the UFC was I go shop can
talk bring Saban and it was a huge like
it was ver doom verse came Velasquez and
Mark Hunt verse I forget there's a huge
car yeah they had me there the whole
weekend yeah no one went over anything
no isn't me no I got to Bristol they
gave me a tour of ESPN which I grew up
watching and I'm like holy [ __ ] the idea
of your suit I'm like yep gave it to the
stylist
they [ __ ] steamed it put on makeup
and then like stage seven to the right
like what now they yeah you're up like
where's the produce what are we
air peace Mike but uh boom next I know
I'm ESPN SportsCenter with Jay Crawford
is it correct we got bread and job here
from lunch like dude what oh wow we
didn't goes guys anything so good that's
so quick yeah let's remember the first
time you saw me box
you saw me the first time when Tony
Jefferies I was in with that Korean kid
big kid who hit really hard and he
wasn't box for either he's why I was I
stopped breathing because I got hit in
the face later I wasn't
in a bar and I was like oh I don't wanna
break my nose I love and I stopped
breathing and I couldn't go on like he I
there were 30 seconds like I was just
too tired you just said I didn't know I
I just hadn't done it so I just didn't
know how to breathe and I was and that
happens to everybody that the manic wait
yeah we had this triathlete it come into
the gym really good athlete try Africa
yeah but he that never sparked he got in
he was just trying to move around he
just don't some somebody was just
throwing pots not hitting him he stopped
breathing
and he about two and a half minutes if
anything like that anything my thing is
on TV though like he had the audition
young it's a college thing he was deeper
than the college thing and it's just
boom he knows I'm gonna die said it do
you know the gift that keeps on giving
yeah something you need badly to you too
bro and I got dope teeth but no your
bottom teeth or that's crooked why I'm
looking very very carefully it can do
little crooks can did two liners can is
a company where I actually don't have to
go into a fricking dentist
and do it all they do it all basically
online it's quite an experience Orthodox
who's licensing you stay creates a
custom treatment plan they show you a 3d
printer you can see how your teeth will
look after your candidates a liners can
help straighten your little stupid
they're good acid or cheaper than
traditional wire braces don't wear wire
braces now treatment takes just six
months on an average and cost sixty five
percent less there's no hassle going
this all can tip straight to you plus in
the season of giving candid donates
twenty-five dollars with each aligner
purchased to smile train who brings safe
one percent free cleft lip and palate
treatment to children around the globe
straighten your teeth and help kids out
it's a no brainer give yourself the gift
of candid why not do can't it see you
owe it to yourself to get straight teeth
see a nd ID can did co.com slash fighter
used code fighter to get seventy five
dollars off that's candid co.com slash
fighter code fighter for seventy five
dollars off get your teeth straight dude
you owe it to yourself and to me because
stare at you twice a week - that's
straight teeth your teeth seriously a
problem your teeth and they make me want
to punch you new days your teeth and
have a lemon shark I've got to be honest
now you have the teeth of a bound
crocodile you would shred me up if I
could throw an apple at your face in a
matte stick get candid dude
it's offensive you got nice lips those
come up yeah that's what we see right
did your teeth Land Shark Lancer candid
captive boom goes the dynamite I'm more
kid yeah it's a poor kid have you ever
ate [ __ ] with shirt on set ah not on set
but certainly that it's like a snowball
effect like I've been bad I've been I've
eaten [ __ ] in auditions for big people
and important jobs when I was younger
I've just been terrible yeah Oh terrible
prepared I had to be no ID to be I to do
law and order like one time and like
when you go on for those people in New
York they get the best actors ever and I
get in there and I have to be I have to
be crazy and in love with my dolls and I
yeah and I and I was I was looking at my
dolls going near my babies I love you
guy and I was so bad and I was like
thank you like when you when you have to
be crazy but you can't do it you're not
you're acting it and you know how bad
you are I was like I'll never go back in
there for them again and I'll so I'm a
terrible actor and also I'm gonna quit
I'm gonna quit have your bill onstage
and you know you skipped like a key tag
or shrine in the shore but I've also
been also like I'm like I I'll find it
down like I know it's weird because I'll
be going through the bit on oh you mean
like young yeah I'm like oh I missed I
missed that beat well I'm gonna try
fitnah don't like it you're going
through it as you're talking and you're
like I'm gonna put it here I wants to
put it over sure it's so strange I've
repeated a joke once because you do to
show sometimes no I know I know
wait I just before yeah that's right so
when I was like yeah did I already yeah
I come out with this now the worst is
when you do a dramatic play which I've
done and I got a full house and I just
can't feel it or find it and I have to
be in and you're like I'm gonna have to
act my way through this and be
absolutely terrible that kind of [ __ ] I
went through a lot of that acting wise
because some pieces some material you
can't you can't do the piece without
having it you have to hate your father
in the piece or you don't have a play
you have to you have to be on drugs you
have to be drunk whatever it is if
you're not it's going to be a very long
night though Morgan it's like it's the
longest night you're gonna feel the
audience move around and Lee is just
terrible and that's what makes you work
hard because you're like I can't be
really bad I'm gonna be yeah all right
you guys heard about that pig attack
right that killed a oh the feral pig
that killed that our feral group a pig
that killed the Texas woman 59 while ago
right was like last week oh no this is
another pegging another Pig the other
one I think you're thinking about is the
wiener dogs that's right
and we could not know that was feral
hogs that likes won't say they are
coming for America yeah so this expert
says that we're essentially doomed by
these pigs unless there's some sort of
big swine flu breaks out yeah because so
there's six million apparently in North
America now feral pigs and two million
of them belong in Texas Jim Kenny will
kill all of them yeah mmm I have a hug
Ted Nugent winning from the helicopter
Regis starts [ __ ] gunning down hard
on my butt they breed so crazy so fast
work out for you to get that ha ha ha ha
I'm so glad I wait on it [ __ ] Daryl peg
killed so that's the one that was killed
there all the taxes in Texas and see the
car she barely locked her door and was
gonna walk to that door to take care of
these two the old an elderly couple and
that's where the pigs detect her and
killed it hold on why are they killing
people though to eat them that is it's
so rare there's only been like four
since the 1800s or some some like that
something really rare but for some
reason there's a bunch that came out and
either
were startled or she had you know Sal's
the Pigott cells and the there's even
salad bytes to like little baby pigs
biting their whoa she lost a lot of
blood and died that way why they kill
people that's the thing it's it's such a
weird thing that happened
that's an awful like that that would
that's bad way to die I don't want to
damage it yeah if I'll die there every
where in Texas Texas find out why to my
family don't tell my kids i dad my big
okay that make up something strong
though no say bull are you [ __ ] bull
stuff okay heart oh yeah okay yeah I
feel like you're people to have a tough
time killing a grown man you know they
start wouldn't your ankles and your lot
of your legs yeah they're also six seven
hundred pounds yeah no I get it
I'm just saying what a [ __ ] boot
delay stupid oh no oh that do nothing Oh
they'd laugh at you this you you Brenda
Sharpe could punch and kick a pig a hog
a feral hog they'd laugh at you they're
pretty fast too are they also have no
neck they also have no head they'd laugh
at you those [ __ ] are yeah you
just have to jump on a something they
said you'll be fine if you just under
something they take it anyway the car
heard you're good they can't swim either
they swim right no I've seen can swim
[ __ ] pigs then no I'll shoot them right
in their heads [ __ ] bacon oh I like I
like bacon too I do
I would have 100% go hog on dude one Pig
no way one pigs like killing know me we
thought war we obsess 3/4 we a problem
yeah problems it'll knock you to the
ground ish kill you bro no one pig would
[ __ ] not a chance where we know this
open field yeah catchy no pass turn your
no no hey open big snap dude hey hey
look at me maybe you you know you you
bring up bring up that mother that
[ __ ] take hold up
that's a warthog now that's a pig feral
wild feral pet monster that that's it
that's a wild boar right there that
thing is killin oh no we're saying pigs
now if it's not boars
not saying boar same thing there's yeah
there's feral pigs so they turn into
these things that's that right there
that right there enjoy that no that's a
warthog dude no what said anything about
a warthog look at me when I was a young
warning no fur on three weeks hold on
look I've talked about the pink pig look
at pink for pink dude okay so so demonic
no no so pink pigs
turn into that
they're out left out for a while yeah
that's what they turn into right away
all right I took it out what I said look
at that mom that'd be a big problem
enjoy that holy [ __ ] I didn't that's a
monster
no wonder they killed us that is [ __ ]
it's rare but yeah they can kill you
holy [ __ ]
well I'm Tim Kennedy's friends - what's
up go that one to eat in the trash yeah
holy [ __ ] and that was crazy is that
real that's real you're actually
athletic those who are terrifying
yeah Hong Kong and they're fast Hogzilla
the biggest wild hog click on that take
a look at them through a portal auxilary
eggs Ulla this one here Hogzilla far far
left gotta start killing them that's
Hogzilla that they killed they're so
thick in there their hair very hard to
hurt oh yeah
cuz even some guns ain't gonna do it yep
like that just a nasty uh I want to go
hog hunting yeah me too now they're
killing people I'll go out there [ __ ]
yeah I'm a I'm not killing in my life
I'll go out there yeah you kill him you
kill uncle right quick - not with my
hands I don't like slit its throat I
want to shoot him with a with an ar-15
I'll do that have a helicopter yeah man
let the paramedics decide you feel me
yep Jesus Christ what else we got
that's scary [ __ ] it is scary this is
supposed to be an optical illusion that
all the kids are talking about
I want tick-tock yeah so Filipino girl
younger Filipino girl she made this
famous apparently and let me know if you
guys notice anything optical illusion
about this
[Music]
does that look like an illusion see at
all she looks beautiful that's what that
look she's very young do it again I
think the VG 17 I don't know tip-top oh
no she's just using that that lead hand
but does it look like it looks weird -
in the Guinness this this looks like it
you said that she used it all I could
see was there doing that yes good dude
your magic oh your magic dark magic nope
let me try again ready they put the
music on oh yeah chicka chicka chicka
Bow oh and then she oh she's gone yeah
[Music]
let me see it one more time
[Music]
I'll see God
good for her man all right tik-tok this
another Drake texting a young girl you
know Billy Eilish is very popular now
you guys talked about it much yes Super
Dome she's 17 years old and she did her
interview with variety she's they asked
her what was the most famous person that
you know and she said Drake text her oh
that's for Emilio Bobby Brown denied
this is her this is why she said it's
like nice dude ever spoken I mean I've
only like text him but he's so nice like
he does not need to be nice you know I
mean he's at a level in his life or he
doesn't need to be nice but he is you
know so people are just going at him
again because Bobby Brown he's 36 years
old why is he texting these younger
girls I think with Billy Eilish though
it's like she's at such a high level of
Fame and in music he's like probably
giving her advice out assume were just
like reaching out cuz he was famous when
he was young too
so maybe yeah I don't think he's trying
to he's not naive or stupid enough to
try and [ __ ] these young girls what he
did remember he dated that girl after he
knew she was really young she's not be
the very first grating yeah yeah and
gorgeous or just something legal sign me
up
yeah I guess the grooming part is were
young man she's beautiful too yeah she's
pretty different she covers up her body
all the time so you can't really tell
what her body looks like you know she's
thick though she seems a little thick
you don't know how about it alright
Willie Nelson he's iconic he's known
from smoking weed well he doesn't smoke
weed anymore he quit Wow
because why do you think I put your dick
answer no no his lungs yeah cuz he's
getting old very old it's like messing
up his lungs then I smoke this house so
much weed all day every day bright
caught up with him on how long he's 85
85 yeah old he's 85 and still doing it
well not anymore
what he's still doing tours he's still
seeing this his son was in uh he's a
guitar player too yeah who's also in uh
what's uh tell me something
yes that movie whatever the [ __ ] that
was with my stars born stars born there
you go
yep there is that's impressive he's 85
85 meant yay
better late than never what about us
what's his most famous song on the road
you are always on my mind yeah you never
let that that's how an Elvis song no
probably new again uh-huh do you have
more yeah I got some more okay how about
this one this is in Florida and a
seven-year-old was surfing they put a
GoPro on his surfboard his dad and him
go surfing all the time and there's a
shark that actually knocked him off his
boards but it's hard to see you know and
it's a small shark but it's pretty cool
oh [ __ ] you see it right there
yeah just do you see him go you hit it I
think there's some slo-moes here yeah he
got he hit hit the shark and shag a
black tip it's a block dip and you'll
see it again here and oh my Sharkies
boom yeah that's just a little thing
okay shark was just afraid he's probably
just swimming and then the surfboard
came in just like that the Santa Cruz
guys out surfing early-morning Santa
Cruz he comes back and he's like a great
white just put me in its mouth what
everybody goes what and he goes a great
white just swallowed me and spit me back
out they go [ __ ]
under his board where his waist is they
see the top they see where is wetsuit is
and there are bite marks at his wetsuit
where his hip is his back is and under
the board their teeth stuck in the
[ __ ] surfboard the shark came up out
of the water and went boom and went oh
god your wood and rubber and spit him
back out in the morning for home I enjoy
that wonder how big it was since he went
all the way into the shark's mouth and
the show got sucked back out
how about that
then there about that story not have any
documented proof but it was told me by
girl about it
that story is 30 years old there is
another story I did I've been telling
story forever and I said maybe it didn't
never happen let me just leave that I'd
let you go for a truck did grab a guy on
a board and throw him do utility ok what
is it you want some more weight go to
great white bite marks you'll see a dude
to get there into that for sure those
teeth get stuck in boards watch this no
no watch this images yeah
images of people who've been bitten by
great whites oh that's gonna be horrible
no it's not because you'll see what they
you can see the stitches all the way
down their body oh here's some that's
not good no but you got to see the
entire yeah you see his back like there
are certain things
they have literally no this one dude
that stitches from here all the way
there all the way down his body we're
gonna call Colin
their son that's horrible
yes those teeth can do two damage oh no
that has to be real I see it click on it
yeah
oh this is a war that was good far right
oh it's getting crazy no we're not
showing this stuff yeah it ate his ass
and his art that's hard to watch
keep going down what are these all real
these are just dead people real looking
that far left one this one or this one
on that one oh my god it gets worse you
don't want to see that stuff with a
blonde I kind of do because I kind of do
cuz I want to make sure your afro I kind
of do because I want to never go don't
show this to anybody of course not oh
that is horrific see what is that oh I'm
saying that's enough well let me just
see not the look how can I not look now
I want to see the other ones oh look at
that when these guys are alive or look
look at how he lost his leg dude yeah
this is terrifying holy [ __ ] yeah but it
makes sense they just they'd use our
body off I mean that one's not real that
Michael Rapaport which one they're the
third one in the middle right there
middles down no this one yeah that was
real that's not real that's fake as [ __ ]
I don't know oh it looks fake yeah it
looks like a movie thing let's fake is
it I hope it's me I hope it's Victor I
hope it is banana for my group the real
same as there's a bunch of them there
let me see that I don't want to see this
stuff no silicone a fiberglass shark
oh no that that the you know I don't
know it is so SFX yeah except I know
what that but a shark did that to him I
think is what saying oh okay so they
were creating what actually happened
Jesus Christ can we move on ones
terrible yeah it's move on this is for
you Brennan I don't know what these are
Travis Scott has a pair of unreleased
Dior Jordans that thousand dollars drop
April 13 yeah oh they're halo 6 those
are the Dior Dior Jordan ones and
they're gonna be there me two K if you
get them from the store which gonna be
impossible then the on the the market
the market value I don't know man who
knows buy 10 G's [ __ ] yeah tight tight
ones those are yours they're there
Jordan and you lad with your and then
there's a picture of him wearing them
and also David Beckham damn those are
sick
those are filthy I'm so into hey hey
killer G some of that shark stuff so
we're not disrespect Oh chin nose
disrespectful I mean the pictures are
like Jays actual Gary from Australia
it's so rare no killer boots man it's
just a small political one kalamullah
camel Harris there's no long everybody
else because she's not ready for our
woman of color but we had a black
president twice ok camel blame blame the
voters for your shitty campaign yeah and
your aimless message and then Trump
tweeted her sucks too bad we will miss
you can don't worry mr. president I'll
see you at your trial for the
impeachment you guys remember that thing
that went on in Starbucks were a cop cop
yeah a guy had pig on it and I think was
this original tweet that's [ __ ] up
so says Kiefer police chief John O'Mara
says that one of his officers picked up
five cups of coffee today at go in pool
tell me the officers made it up I know
but
his daughter said that he actually is a
pig
she's a verified Twitter user - she said
he's a racist and all this other stuff
Oh [ __ ] I don't know what a [ __ ] we're
to do that to your father well well
let's find out what the dad said but or
what the dad did I mean this is a he
said she said thing where would you be
with that but boys she saved about her
dad that he's just not goes I'd like to
say right here just like to say they
absolutely a pig I like to thank the
brave men okay well they put all lost
their jobs so thank you for that for the
record my father has zero business being
a police officer he was blatantly
proudly racist when I was a kid said
things I would never repeat he treats
women like dogs and clean his own
daughter she sounds like therapist
18,000 followers how many around 18,000
yeah but meanwhile what yes we like to
ride I have no idea [ __ ] or she's a
mess
or she's she's I mean we don't know by
the way but it's just interesting that
his daughter came out to say he is a pig
it's also weird and [ __ ] up and and he
wants the cop wanted that person or the
people that were fired from Starbucks to
get their jobs back that's nice that's
pretty gracious yeah also and one last
one America's Got Talent
I guess there's a lot of drama going on
because two girls got fired did you hear
well he got fired you know so appreciate
this you know that's one of the reasons
I've I think I know you're talking about
come with the other one but yeah
Gabrielle Gabrielle Union was a was a
judge on there they brought Jay Leno on
been a comic for how many years 60
[ __ ] years and he made some joke
Asian joke there they should there's
like a dog
he said something like so it's Simon
Cowell in the hallway there's a picture
or drawing of Simon Cowell with a bunch
of dogs around him and he said something
like to the extent of you better be
careful if you go to somewhere like it
looks like it looks like a menu item or
something on a Korean restaurant it
looks on something like that a joke -
that good joke it's okay the lame joke a
joke but just kind of like a joke
obvious joke but agenda yeah most of us
would weld Union went to the execs was
like I don't complain a fear and
how can you let me go this joke Caprio
union said that that's what that's what
the rumors already there they're also
saying that Simon Cowell and some other
people inside that that whole world they
when she would wear her hair a certain
way they wouldn't be it'll be too black
or something like that should they said
there's complaints of that I never said
that and then that's what they're all
saying ever said that there's no way
Simon Cowell he's seduced my she's
that's too bad she's also only dates
black girls yes you know that sheet now
I didn't I remember he did take that
really pretty easy on these black girls
yeah so he's super race yeah so so at
the end of the day this is her coming up
with a way to get some money out of her
firing keep scrolling down you know I'm
Gabriel you and julianne hough for the
cup says or shade the explosive
situation he has a set up so this is
about Howard Stern's view on it and how
strong was there for a long time it
hated it
he has said setup that the men stay no
matter how old they are no matter how
fat they are no matter how ugly their no
matter countless they are but what he
managed to do on all the shows he
replaced the hot chicks with hotter
chicks and younger chicks which is
obvious that's pretty much his statement
that's it yeah
whereas Gabrielle Union where she oh and
she's there she's very pretty yet she's
dating or she's married so she doing
Dwyane Wade and they have a gay thought
yeah and they just took a lot of heat
cuz in there like Thanksgiving picture
the gay son he was wearing a crop top
and had faking it yes he is like long
like acrylics like acrylic nails how old
is he yeah I did like 10 or 11 then they
took him to gay parade I don't know as
teach it so there you go yeah I don't
know yeah I don't know I don't give a
[ __ ] but also but also Simon Cowell it's
like it's his show and if maybe he
thought they saw the judges in that one
yeah we can make someone else in here
yeah who gives a fun yeah exactly
I mean you know maybe they what the best
day not you know I really would have
seen the show but I don't think the best
judges and also you can people get fired
yes maybe you're just but it's also his
show he creates a show yeah cool see you
guys was a
maybe Chinese a man yeah I like them
it's my show yeah man get fired two
votes him that's why I love why men
knows the thoughts let's chance you and
I love watching Hard Knocks I love
sports this way hey [ __ ]
I don't care where you're from you came
from a tough upbringing I'm watching you
you're not gonna go anywhere
you suck either get it together get in a
d1 program if you're lucky enough you'll
play in the NFL or we'll see you later
and that's what happens then you get to
raters training camp I did never knew I
never knew football was this discipline
this cruel like it's no joke it's like
it's like the army it's like it really
isn't and and you either do it or not in
there and they go like this they go you
bye see you later
I can't leave never seen hard lines
before it's it's it's amazing it's it's
so even that military to be okay it's
edited right but you hear these coaches
and they're just like what the [ __ ] are
you don't you know it's there's a
there's a football player I don't know
who he is but in the NFL who had his
girlfriend or wife just died from a
crocs in it and then they let him go
right after I heard about that too it's
like it's a business it's on business
yeah they don't care they're just like
if you're not that we're not doing
bottom line yeah it's bottom line it's
bottom line you do get pretty
thick-skinned imagine yeah oh yeah you
know but the other thing is I didn't
know this either
they bring in players every Tuesday to
try out for your position yep so you're
just constantly under threat and if the
guy is just better we're gonna play him
that's the best how do you hear that
you've been benched they tell you they
just say he's starting today you know oh
okay do you want another one
just to lighten the mood oh yeah it's
good sure I mean this that Howard Stern
didn't bum me out I think guys eat get
their legs eat nah that was horrible I
don't wanna watch this give me one more
well where's not that new but we were
just wondering what happened to Elijah
Wood and I guess we were in cash okay
Elijah Wood early this is still in
November - James Dean's GGI casting oh
how they're bringing back yeah and CGI
and like all this [ __ ] well that looks
like Robert De Niro in the Irishman
[ __ ] there's no future in it
Zelda Williams who's late father Ramos
has restricted his image spoke out oh
they don't want them to recreate a man
that I get it so you guys are all have
done acting stuff what do you guys think
of it I don't care you don't care if it
was you bringing me back yeah and CGI
it's just it's just history it's like
the family can still make money though
like you're silly and paid like I'm no
problem all right
hologram it's gonna happen but he's way
younger
no yeah we just make you younger way
more hip yeah should be they're gonna be
able to do all that stuff yeah it looks
like it's going it's already happening
so good luck trying to change that I
don't know it's just jelly accept it
technology part of performance I mean I
get it they put they put on hangsen it
was great so and some of those people
were dead like down on okay Franklin
Roosevelt I'm not going to a concert of
a hologram a [ __ ] Michael Jackson
tell you that right now okay me to you
is that it that's it all right good man
good podcast kids wrench it Wednesday
promise your wedding day bright can't
wait to get out of here and go hit on
the do dude shooter shoot haters hate
fat chicks eat go over there and hit
them up dude that's who makes those
shoes desert these New Balance
Woodstock's your bounce let's collab
your in the collab now where does a man
get collabs where do you get the craves
yeah not for you they're a website not
you know I understand but is there's
several websites you can go to sneakers
you got a goat you can go to stock X
okay you don't have an account well what
if I wanted to kill can I get on here
piggyback your account no because I got
it when I get in the Raffles okay and
there's a big shoot dropped in this out
of it when I get in the Raffles it's
only one size 13 13 well it's my I have
to put my size I can't or I won't win
the shoe gotcha
I'll just go buy them you can't let the
gun the gun
I'll just go I want one of those size
ten and a half
now they don't have to start by some
dude shooter shoot fat chicks eat go
over there and take your shot at homeboy
but why don't they why don't they have
um why don't they [ __ ] these or
Woodstock's dude why don't they I'm
gonna store because to rear not for
everybody how many do they make I don't
know three those the ones you got on the
website these are ones I got with
certain website exclusives all right
pairs of shoes do you own that bro I
don't know dude pride 200 let's take
some of your cool shoes and put them in
place of these greats I'm getting bored
of these great you're bored of the great
huh I don't put my nice shoes up here I
wear them put them up there mm-hmm
mm-hmm
would you do create another shoe yeah
let's let's do a collab a fans got
somebody here this up that's good this
two rinks weekly sure yeah look like
Freddy Krueger's feet yeah me thick yeah
like a little old leather just wrinkly a
[ __ ] sure let's do a wrinkles purse and
then okay another of my yeah kind of
like a ruddy pink yeah look less
wrinkled and with my eyes color flesh
wrinkled flesh Franco fresh fresh link
oh my [ __ ] it rains come see this this
Friday Saturday Kansas City the old
flesh wrinkles won't be with me Kansas
City are you okay Friday Saturday Kansas
City and meeting all your barbecue and
get my dick out
Kansas City improv Friday Saturday get
your tickets next week Atlanta City
Borgata one night only one show only
them stick around watching the UFC with
you filthy animals then December 19th
through 21st I'm in San Diego La Jolla
The Comedy Store and just announced
Oklahoma City two shows one night on the
27th and Tulsa one show one night on
28th of December and January is getting
crunk as well
Foxwoods Connecticut January 10th then
the Wilbur is almost sold out we're
gonna have extra show if you guys tell
that [ __ ] out
day now that's Wilbert January 11th get
Rodriguez t5k calm
Brian Phoenix little hazel be with Brian
yeah
Phoenix celebrity theater the 21st of
December I'm excited about that that I
got Boston the 31st aust has New Year's
Boston Boston at the Wilbur theater New
Year's Eve let's sell that [ __ ] out and
have some fun I'm excited New Year's Eve
Wilbur Boston come come get someone
what's that it dude
all right listen guys just the final kid
and the haze we're out